also ich finde es wichtig einfach mal zu
erklären der der Blackout ist halt ganz
was anderes als der Stromausfall und das
Hauptproblem was wir haben ist dass in
den Medien immer Blackout gesagt wird
aber es sind eigentlich Stromausfälle
über die man von den Folgen her spricht
und der Unterschied ist ganz einfach
erklärt der Stromausfall ist ein lokales
Ereignis das kann natürlich auch was
Größeres sein die 25 im Münsterland aber
im Grunde es werden irgendwelche
Strommasten umgelegt ein Trafohäuschen
brennt ab oder ein Kabel wird beschädigt
und dann ist ein Region ohne Strom
bedeutet aber nicht das gesamte
Stromnetz ist ohne Strom sondern nur
diese Region wir haben mehrere
Spannungsebenen höchstspannung
Hochspannung Mittelspannung
Niederspannung und auf einer der unteren
ist dann der Strom weg haben wir einen
Blackout passiert ganz was anderes die
Kraftwerke schalten sich aus zum
Eigenschutz vom Netz weg und das
bedeutet nichts hat mehr Strom und das
bedeutet auch nichts tut es mehr und das
ist halt das Riesenproblem weil erstens
mal haben wir kaum noch schwarz
stattfähige Kraftwerke also Kraftwerke
die aus eigener Kraft wieder dann
hochfahren können dass das eine Problem
und das zweite ist alle Daten du kannst
alles was mit Computer mit Internet und
so zu tun hat ist auch weg und beim
Stromausfall ist es so der Strom kommt
irgendwann wieder weil der strommastoder
repariert dann funktioniert alles wieder
beim Blackout funktioniert dann
vielleicht der Strom wieder aber alle
Daten Dienste tun es eben nicht mehr vor
allen Dingen und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt alle Hilfskräfte sind
auch betroffen das heißt es wird ja
immer gesagt ja dann können Hilfskräfte
kommen und die tun hier und die tun da
geht aber nicht die haben ja auch alle
Familie die sitzen ja auch alle dann zu
Hause und kümmern sich um ihre Familie
und das ist das Riesenproblem und es
wird ganz Deutschland und wenn man Pech
haben ganz Europa treffen wie
wahrscheinlich ist das dass wir diesen
Blackout bekommen ich sag 99,9 Prozent
und zwar aus dem einzigen Grund also ich
kann nicht hellsehen ich habe auch keine
Wahrsager
es passiert auf jeden Fall erläutern der
Punkt ist einfach folgender ich möchte
dass die Menschen sich vorbereiten ich
betrachte es wie eine Versicherung
Brandschutzversicherung
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung alles
Sachen die schließen wir ab in der
Hoffnung wir brauchen sie nicht was
passiert in der Stadt wie hier in Berlin
wenn sich die Menschen nicht vorbereiten
dann ist hier nach zwei Tagen
Bürgerkrieg und deswegen wäre es so
wichtig dass sich jeder vorbereitet weil
dann sind die menschlichen Katastrophen
abgewendet und dann gibt es nur noch
wirtschaftliche Katastrophen und
deswegen sage ich 99,9 aber das
österreichische Innenministerium rechnet
damit experten rechnen damit ich rechne
damit es ist halt wenn man mal weggeht
von den politischen Meinungsführern dann
rechnen alle damit das ist passiert
Blackout Experte daran verdienen wenn
der Blackout kommt gar nichts dann ist
mein Geschäft tot ich kann nur so lange
was verdienen wie ich Leute beraten kann
in dem Moment wo ich keinen mehr beraten
kann verdiene ich nichts das heißt der
Panik verdienen sie dann natürlich schon
dass sie jetzt beraten können das Wort
Panik ich will keine Panik machen
sondern ich will sauber aufklären ich
kann alles mit Zahlen Daten Fakten
belegen und ich will dass die Menschen
sich vorbereiten ich finde es zum
Beispiel verantwortungslos dass unser
Bundeskanzler im Sommer Interview gesagt
hat er hat alles im Griff es wird keinen
Bl was geben das kann er nicht weil er
kann kein Wetter machen es kann kein
Erdbeben geben es kann Extremwetter
geben es kann menschliches Versagen
technisches Versagen
komplexitätsversagen es kann
cyberangrifft es kann Terror geben hat
er das alles im Griff hat er nicht wir
haben in einem Interview gesagt dass sie
davor warnen Aufzug zu fahren halten sie
sich selber daran ja wenn immer es geht
fahre ich keinen Aufzug mehr sie nehmen
nur noch die Treppe ja weil wenn sie mal
für Berlin rechnen es hat man untersucht
und man schätzt man braucht fünf Tage
bis man alle Leute aus den Aufzügen
befreit hat wie gesagt Hilfskräfte sind
alle Betroffene sie es gibt auch keine
Kommunikation zwischen den Hilfskräften
das heißt bis da die Leute gerettet sind
sind die meisten tot
wenn man das hier hört Herr jungnischke
möchte keine Panik machen ich empfinde
jetzt Panik wenn ich an den Aufzug denke
aber wie wahrscheinlich ist denn dass
diese Prognose eintritt oder wie
bereitet sich die Bundesregierung darauf
vor also er hat ja davon gesprochen dass
es Erdbeben Anschläge Cyberangriffe
geben natürlich gibt es diese extrem
sexualien und es ist extrem Szenarien
ist natürlich auch ein Blackout nicht
ausgeschlossen dass er 99,9 %
wahrscheinlich ist halte ich für Unsinn
sich nach Möglichkeit vorzubereiten kann
nie schaden ja also auch an vernünftigen
Wasservorrat haben ja wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gut genug aber Wasservorrat
habe ich jedenfalls zu Hause aber die
die wir haben schon eine ganze Reihe von
Systemen um einen solchen Blackout zu
vermeiden und zu verhindern ich bin
selber vor zehn Jahren Verbraucherschutz
Senator geworden da haben wir eine Übung
gemacht das in Berlin vier Tage lang der
Strom nicht geht die Berliner Polizei
bereitet sich jetzt ja auch vor die
gesamte Berliner Verwaltung ich war ja
nicht bei der Polizei die gesamte
Berliner Verwaltung hat drei Tage
sozusagen eine Übung gemacht hatte auch
Ergebnisse wo wir dringenden
Verbesserungsbedarf und hatte gar nicht
mit mir zu tun ich war sozusagen nur
verpflichtet mitzuüben ja
die
also die die Lage ist nicht so wie er
beschreibt aber ganz kurz also da muss
ich mal dazwischen gehen es ist glaube
ich in der Mitte also das ist hier fast
schon Scholz mäßig beruhigend wir haben
heute
überall lesen können der Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur immerhin der
zuständige für die Sicherheit der
bereitet sich genau auf sowas vor dass
es Situationen gibt und das ist so ein
bisschen der Unterschied ob es
tatsächlich zum Blackout kommt wenn es
gut läuft und dazu gibt es jetzt neue
digitale
Systeme was einem vielleicht auch nicht
gerade beruhigt stimmte aber eben sie
sollen eigentlich auf neuestem Stand
zumindest sein dass wenn man kommen
sieht dass es nicht reicht
nimmt man die Großabnehmer einfach vom
Netz also das heißt diejenigen die bei
uns den meisten strompaar eben
Verminderung verhindern
es ist es geht darum das zu verhindern
der
bundesnetzagentures mit Klaus Müller und
es begabte immer am Wochenende dass der
Städte und Gemeindebund warnt vor
Blackouts und den Bürgern dringend dreht
Vorräte für den Fall immerhin zu haben
so sie sind schon Zustände das ist was
anderes als vor ein paar Jahren wo man
sagte das ist so naja also in
Deutschland gibt es auch manchmal eine
Erdbeben irgendwie aber das ist so
schwache das ist jetzt keine Katastrophe
das hier ist
derart nahe gekommen ich glaube auch
nicht an 99,9 Prozent aber allein die
Tatsache dass wir davon abhängig sein
werden dass Frankreich sein
Atomstrom einigermaßen wieder hochfährt
dass versuche irgendwie Kohle durch den
durch den Rhein schippern können all das
was im Moment nicht der Fall ist und
dann eben mit diesen Schwankungen im
Bereich der Erneuerbaren die ja schon in
Normalzeiten extrem viel Feinsteuerung
bedürfen da muss ich sagen ist das
Risiko dann nicht mehr in einem Bereich
der ganz unwahrscheinlich ist im
Lohnbereich eins zu einer Million
sondern er ist sehr viel größer und das
ist das ist
möglich wie kann sich denn dann der
Bürger vorbereiten also was sollte ich
jetzt tun ich habe mich bislang noch
nicht da vorbereitet
ja das Wichtigste ist Wasser dann
natürlich Nahrungsmittel Medikamente
weil wenn es zum Blackout kommt was ich
natürlich auch nicht hoffe dann wird die
Versorgung über Wochen bis Monate
zusammenbrechen Zahlungsmittel weil es
funktioniert dann auch kein Bankautomat
das sind so mal die wesentlichen Dinge
aber ich habe noch einen Beweis dafür
dass es langsam brenzlig wird weil es
wird ja hier gesagt ich mache nur Panik
retispatch also retispatch-maßnahmen
sind ja die Eingriffe der Netzbetreiber
die nötig sind um das Netz stabil zu
halten im Jahr 2000 gab es so gut wie
keine 20 15 waren 62800
6382 20 20 6.797
8635 und 2022 bis gestern
9.388 das heißt wir sind der
exponentiellen Kurve so und das Problem
ist also sind immer Maßnahmen die die
Netzbetreiber ergreifen müssen das Netz
stabil zu halten wenn die aber so
explodieren und wir sind dieses Jahr
wahrscheinlich dann bei 15
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
irgendwann nicht mehr reicht ist relativ
groß und was hier auch immer vergessen
wird das stimmt einfach nicht also
blackoutfit bitte nicht die Wörter im
Mund rumdrehen ich habe nur gesagt das
ist ein Indiz dafür wie viel die
Netzbetreiber tun müssen um das Netz am
Laufen zu halten und was wir auch nicht
vergessen dürfen wir haben einen
europäischen Stromverbund aus 37 Ländern
bestehen man hat dummerweise die Ukraine
dazu geholt da wird Krieg geführt und
wir haben großstörungen gehabt im
letzten Jahr im Januar die Ursache lag
in Kroatien und hätte fast zum Blackout
geführt stand im Handelsblatt wir haben
im Juli eine gehabt das war zwischen
Frankreich und Spanien eine Krise hätte
auch europaweit fast zum Blackout
geführt und dann kommen Leute und sagen
ist alles easy passiert nichts das
verantwortungslos
ehrlich
nur etwas relativiert richtig und die
und das ist einfach eine Frage der
Sachlichkeit also die Videos patchen ist
ja gerade die Maßnahme um das Netz
auszugleichen jetzt würden sie jetzt
einmal erklären
also wir haben einen Strommarkt der den
hätte es am Vortag werden die
wesentlichen Strommengen gehandelt nach
dem Wetterbericht und den Prognosen
wieder Strom Handel ist so und nun
ändert sich das Leben aber es wird doch
mehr verbraucht es irgendetwas fällt aus
das Wetter ist schlechter als geplant
und dann sind diese Mengen sozusagen
nicht vertraglich gebunden und wenn sie
dann auch noch an Situationen haben wie
jetzt wir haben einen
ukrainekrieg natürlich
verunsichert die Ukraine momentan die
stromsicherheit das ist gar keine Frage
das ist so ist aber wir können die ja
jetzt in der jetzigen Situation noch
nicht abklemmen wir haben gasmangel wir
haben die größte Dürre seit 500 Jahren
mit der Dürre ist sowohl die Steinkohle
betroffen die Wasserkraft ist in Europa
maximal niedrig und die französischen
Atomkraftwerke sind in sanierungspausen
diese diese gleichzeitige Menge hat das
Stromnetz natürlich
weniger stabil gemacht und deswegen
müsste es mehr risespatch-maßnahmen
geben und ich will auch nicht
ausschließen dass es stromausfäl haben
sie ja selber am Anfang entwickelten
Unterschied zwischen Stromausfällen und
Blackout das ist auch wichtig so
könnten auch bei den
en oder schwarz-grünen
bin ich wieder seiner Meinung noch bin
ich seinem co-gänger ich finde auch
Angela gestanden also auch einer der
Merkel hat ja immer versucht die Dinge
sehr sachlich zu sehen wenn sich an ihre
Erklärungen in Corona zu sehen und ich
fand mich umsonst war sie deswegen eine
populäre Politikerin also um noch mal
zurück zur Sachlichkeit zu gehen das
Risiko ist eindeutig gestiegen weil die
Umgebungsfaktoren viel schlechter
geworden sind
aber dass das jetzt zu 99,9 Prozent
passiert ist Unsinn aber es ist
natürlich richtig gerade wenn man
betroffen ist Medikamente dauerhaft
braucht
nicht in der Nähe eines
trinkwasserflusses
abgeben weil das wäre ja nicht sachlich
wahrscheinlich aber ich habe gar keine
Datengrundlage um ihn hier zu sagen aber
die die es gibt eine ganze Industrie die
daran arbeitet das ist nicht passiert
und dafür muss auch gut bezahlt wird so
kann immer mal der Himmel Einschüssen ja
fokussieren hätten sie mich vor sechs
Monaten gefragt ob es Krieg in der
Ukraine gibt hätte ich ihm gesagt nein
und es wäre falsch gewesen und so war
das jede Prognose falsch rum vorsichtig
sein aber umgekehrt kann man nicht sagen
es ist fast sicher das ist passiert
fühlen sie sich denn jetzt gut abgeholt
wohin tendieren sie mehr wie geht es
Ihnen jetzt hier mit dem Szenarien also
fühle ich mich überhaupt nicht weil die
Frage ist ja mich als Bürger der in
einer Millionenstadt lebt wenn dort drei
Tage der Strom ausfällt die Menschen
kein Wasser haben kein Essen kaufen
können weil ja alles elektronische nicht
mehr funktioniert nicht bei mir die
Türen der Supermärkte würden was will
der Staat machen um Chaos und
Ausschreitungen und Gewalt zu verhindern
weil das was man nicht hat wird man sich
holen und wenn man sich das beim
Nachbarn holt oder beim Kiosk oder
letztendlich beim Supermarkt wie will
man das verhindern will man nur die
Polizei einsetzen soll die Bundeswehr
vielleicht eventuell eingesetzt werden
wie will man Chaos verhindert das ist
nämlich genau das wovor die Menschen
auch Angst haben man kann drei Tage ohne
Strom überleben aber was ist danach wer
sorgt für meine Sicherheit weil die
Kommunikation selber ist ja auch
zusammengebrochen wie werde ich die
Polizei zum Beispiel
anrufen können weil wir gerade Gewalt
angetan wird also das kann ich Ihnen
sagen dafür gibt's Pläne ob die wie gut
die dann funktionieren wird auch nicht
alles funktionieren
das hat nichts funktioniert
an Fehlleistungen gebracht haben aber
die Rettung nach dem Hochwasser hat
schon funktioniert da waren leider
natürlich über 100 Menschen tot das ist
auch nicht wieder gut zu machen und auch
sonstige Schäden sind schwer wieder gut
zu machen aber das ist dann keine
Rettungsaktion gibt natürlich gibt es
dann Rettungsplan der erste Plan ist das
ist Notstromversorgung für Krankenhäuser
gibt weil mir aber nichts ich wollte
ihnen ja sagen sie wollte ja fragen was
dann passiert so die selbstverständlich
wird die Polizei in den notbereitschaft
gesetzt und muss auch die Feuerwehr und
weitere Sicherheitsbehörden und wir
können dann eine Reihe von Maßnahmen bis
zur Ausgangssperren machen wenn es
wirklich dazu käme dass die Leute noch
im übrigen gibt es dann auch eine
Notversorgung mit Lebensmitteln für die
also das ist nicht so dass da überhaupt
keine notfallprobleme eingesetzt werden
also erstens die Bundeswehr kann nicht
zu Sicherheitsorganen nach unserem
Grundgesetz eingesehen die konnte jetzt
also gesetzlich erst geändert rein die
Bundeswehr Bundeswehr kann nicht im
Inneren für Sicherheit sorgen sie darf
aber im Inneren Amtshilfe leisten sprich
sie dürfte Lebensmittel verteilen aber
sie dürfte jetzt nicht mit ihren Waffen
sie davon abhalten ihn zu überfallen das
darf die Bundeswehr nicht dass eine
Lehre aus der Weimarer Republik und
jetzt dann aber auch nicht weil in Köln
haben wir zum Beispiel polizeimangel
also die Polizei kann nicht überall
gleichzeitig sein es funktioniert
überhaupt nicht also kann ja überhaupt
unterstützen am Ende der Boss Funk
funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht im
Notfall wenn Blackout ist und ich kann
auch nicht die ganze Zeit im Vorfeld
Vorräte anlegen weil dazu reicht auch
die Kapazität meiner Wohnung nicht und
ähm ja also viele Dinge werden einfach
nicht funktionieren wo werden zum
Beispiel
Wasserstellen auf genau dass die Bürger
dort sich Wasser oder Nahrungsmittel
holen können wie wird das denn
kompliziert sie sagen es gibt Pläne aber
die Kommunikation zuständig also warum
bisher war eine Webseiten auf wo die
Bürger drauf gehen können
auch im Vorfeld aufzuklären wo was wie
geschehen ist sicher da gibt es nicht
das würde aber jetzt natürlich in dem
Land da muss ich einmal sagen sehr sehr
viel Panik verbreiten wenn jetzt hier
habe ich mit katastrophenplänen für
möglichen Blackout um die Ecke kommen
würde da wäre ich glaube ich nicht die
Einzige die das kommentieren würde von
wegen
wir haben in der Nähe eines
Kernkraftwerkes
bevorraten soll ja dann denke ich auch
nicht dass morgen dann eine Kernschmelze
stattfindet also darum geht es nicht wir
haben ein Bundesamt für
Katastrophenschutz in Köln die auf der
Bundesebene zuständig sind in den
Kommunen gibt es entsprechende
Darstellung ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt
nicht dafür zuständig ich es tut jetzt
so als wenn ich sage jeder kann dieser
Krisenpläne ist wirklich gut gelungen
dass du dich gar nicht sagen
und insofern ist es gut wenn man darüber
redet und diese Pläne nachschärft aber
sozusagen das Gefühl ist passiert zu
99,9 Prozent und dann haben wir gar
keine Ahnung was passiert stimmt einfach
nicht wir haben ja das Problem ist also
dass man vielleicht auch regiert wir
haben wir haben wir haben das Bundesamt
anders ausgestattet wir haben einen
neuen Leiter gegangen der ist jetzt
eigentlich Innenminister in Sachsen
geworden also lange Rede kurzer Sinn da
ist auch schon einiges passiert sie
können immer mit gutem Recht sagen ist
noch nicht genug aber das ist gar nichts
gibt es